وانظر أنا ابن طبيب وممرضة
أه وثانيًا أتفهم ميل
الناس في الجمهور لمجرد تصديق
الأطباء الذين نريد أن نصدق
الأطباء ولكن علينا أيضًا أن نلاحظ أن
هناك تاريخًا طويلًا وقبيحًا في هذا
البلد  لم يكن الرؤساء صادقين بشأن
صحتهم مع الأمريكيين
والأطباء الذين تم استخدامهم كجزء من هذا
التستر قبل
100 عام ، كان وودرو ويلسون
إف دي آر جون كينيدي رونالد ريغان أم مرارًا وتكرارًا.
بايدن
قلت ،
هل جعلته يقدم تعهدًا ، هل
سيكون دائمًا صريحًا بشأن
جميع جوانب صحته آه في الوقت الفعلي
لا نحصل على ذلك من دونالد
ترامب وفريقه في الوقت الحالي ، فنحن لا
نحصل على
جميع الحقائق لماذا
أنا بخير  أنت تعلم أنني سأضطر إلى القول
إنهم هم يخفون
أشياء جايك ، أعني أنني أكره أن أقول ذلك ،
لكنهم لا
يتسمون بالشفافية الكاملة بشأن هذا
وأعتقد أنه  موقف مؤسف حقًا
للدكتور كولين كما قال
عشية  كل ما سمعته عنه كان
لا تشوبه شائبة ، لكن من الواضح أنه تم
إخباره بما يجب قوله
وما لا يجب قوله وكيفية تقديم
الأشياء ويجب أن يقول
انظر أريد أن أطلع الناس على أنني
محترف
ولكني  إذا كنت سأقوم بإطلاع الناس ، فأنا
بحاجة إلى أن أكون قادرًا على الإجابة على جميع
الأسئلة بصدق وإعطاء جميع
التفاصيل ذات الصلة لأنه من الأمور
التي تعرفها أو لا تفعلها على الإطلاق أو لا
تفعل ذلك على الإطلاق لأنه صعب للغاية  أن
تثق
أو تصدق أو تفهم كل
ما يقوله
بسبب ذلك ، يجب أن أجلس
هنا جايك وأترجم
الملاحظات التي تعرفها بعد ذلك ،
لدي كل هذه الملاحظات التي
جمعتها معًا لمحاولة
اكتشاف  بالضبط ما يقوله
ما الذي تريد أن تعرفه إذا كان بإمكانك
طلب خمسة أو ستة
حقائق من أه القائد كونلي أو أو
العقيد
دوولي الأطباء ماذا تريد أن تعرف
عن صحة الرئيس ترامب ،
أولاً وقبل كل شيء ، أنت تعلم أن هذا
فيروس الجهاز التنفسي
نحتاج إلى معرفة الموظفين  من
رئتيه تعلم أنه أمر لا يصدق بالنسبة لي
أننا طرحنا هذا السؤال مرات عديدة
هل يعاني من التهاب رئوي ، ما الذي
أظهرته الأشعة السينية على صدره والذي كان بالتأكيد
قد خضع لفحص مقطعي للصدر ، هذه
الأشياء مهمة سأفعلها
يود حقًا معرفة هذه الأشياء
من حيث اكتشاف مخاطره الإجمالية في
الوقت الحالي ، لكنك تعلم أيضًا
نوع
مساره السريري المحتمل للمضي قدمًا ، فنحن
نعلم أن هذا المرض يسبب
الكثير من الالتهابات ويمكن أن يؤثر على العديد من الأعضاء المختلفة
في الجسم.  الرئتين فقط
ولكن أجهزة أعضاء القلب الأخرى
قالوا بشكل مثير للاهتمام أنهم قالوا إن
وظائف الكبد والكلى القلبي لديه
طبيعية أو
تتحسن بشكل جيد وأنا أثبت من
ذلك لأنك قلت أنها كانت طبيعية
بالأمس وكذلك لم تكن
طبيعية في وقت ما
أرغب في معرفة مستوى
الالتهاب في جسمه ، فهناك بعض
اختبارات الدم التي يمكنك
مراقبتها لإعطاء
فكرة عما يبدو عليه هذا الالتهاب
وهل هو غير طبيعي؟  التجوال أو الرد
على بعض هذه الأدوية التي
يحصل عليها ،
أود أن أعرف كما
أشرت جيك تاريخ آخر
اختبار سلبي له لأن هذه
القصة بأكملها لا تزال غير منطقية
، تم تشخيصه ليلة الخميس وكان
لديه مثل هذه السرعة  انخفاض
غير محتمل لدى الأشخاص الذين تعرفهم ،
عادة ما يكون هناك بضعة أيام على الأقل
بعد تشخيص شخص ما
قبل أن يبدأوا في الإصابة بالتراجع أه
بسبب فترة الحضانة
ونوع الفيروس يتكاثر ويبدأ
في التسبب في أعراض
إما أنه تعرض بشكل كبير
جدًا لهذا  الفيروس الذي تسبب في
إصابته بالمرض بسرعة كبيرة
أو أن هذا الجدول الزمني لا معنى
له ولا معنى له